tonight for the marlins pablo lopez on
the mound pablo comes in three and one
with a 1.98 earned run average two out
base is empty it leaves it for yandy
diaz here's the 3-2
swing and a miss put him away tonight's
starter for the tampa bay rays
left-hander josh fleming making his
second big league start on sunday versus
toronto got the win in this big league
debut that'll bring garrett cooper to
the plate vr holds in the pitch swing
and a miss he struck him out perez held
on to it now the right hand hitting
willy adams now it's willie adams
dribbler pablo with the bare hand and a
long stretch by leiwan diaz over at
first so we'll see if manuel can come
through two for three yesterday
here's the three one and here's a ground
ball off the top of the mound out behind
second vr has it throws to first for the
out and the side is retired and choi is
stranded at third base
two down here and jorge alfaro comes up
on three and one the left-hander throws
swinging a little tapper back
towards the mount fleming's got it he
turns and goes to first in time for the
out so
once again
the pitchers are fielding their
positions well today and both starters
appear to be in charge at the end of two
rays and marlins are scoreless going out
for garrett cooper who struck out in
inning number one blake snell and sandy
alcantara
the pitching matchup tomorrow garrett
cooper down the left field line that one
is foul
almost knocked out the one of the
cinnamon toast crunch
cinnamon g's out there
2-2 and that's drilled into center field
but right there is kiermeier just short
of the warning track to handle that two
up and two down
and
manuel margot will be the batter he
grounded out his first time he's going
to work the pitch and a ball chopped
toward third charged by anderson unloads
quickly throws to first the speedy
margot is out and a very quick top of
the fifth that goes five to three
nothing across for tampa bay we're
scoreless in the middle of the fifth one
down nobody on
and jorge alfaro
coming up two-two pitch swinging and i
miss he struck him out he went up with
off speed and got alfaro to change the
eye level and that's strikeout number
five two down and here is lewis brinson
one ball one strike here it is swinging
a fly ball off the end of the bat to
shallow center kamar sprinting in
running across diagonally to his right
and he makes the catch to retire the
side another one two three inning and
that's nine in a row for
joshua fleming at the end of five two
out second and third and now we'll take
something from yandy diaz
2-0 the outfield is deep
here for diaz and the pitch slow bouncer
towards up the third base line anderson
with a barehand pickup and has no play
it's an infield single for yandy diaz
and perez scores it's one nothing raise
perez crosses the plate
as middles goes into third
well diaz couldn't hit the ball much
softer and that played to the reigns
advantage kimon choi is single to right
knee is grounded a second one for two
one and two here it comes
doesn't get any better than that pablo
fooled him got it over
it was a four-seam fastball at 96 had
plenty behind it and caught the strike
zone the rookie
jesus sanchez struck out his first time
up now fleming throws swinging a miss he
struck him out and that was in the heart
of the plate
another 91 mile an hour fastball it has
all kind of movement to it that's six
strikeouts now
josh fleming and with
about 10 in a row and 15 out of 17
retired here's jonathan villar veteran
player
single to right and caught stealing and
popped to first and now thompson deals
swinging a ground ball lightly head
towards second fielding his window he's
got it flips to first in time thompson
gets out of it the shutout is intact and
the rays have thrown 33 consecutive
scoreless innings at marlin's part
williams
ready to lead off
payoff pitch and anonymous swings and
misses he's down on strikes good change
up from lopez that's his fifth strikeout
so two outs runner at second base and
here's kevin pierre-meyer see what they
do here on on one with wendell leaning
at second base the pitch he goes inside
and grounds one through the middle and
into center field for a base hit wendell
around third he's going to come in and
score
kiermeier takes a wide turn at first but
he's satisfied with an rbi single and
the rays take a two-nothing lead and now
the catcher michael perez to the plate
on o-1 there's a high fly ball
shallow left center bertie and brinson
and brinson makes the catch
to end the inning one batter too late
ray's attack on a run on a couple of
hits they leave a man
time to stand and sing here at marlins
park it's the seventh inning stretch now
gets wendell to the plate who has
already doubled in this game
and here's your chance razer is single
away from perhaps doubling their lead
two and two the count to wendell in the
pitch swung out and lifted right field
and deep sanchez going back on the run
it's over his head and one hops the wall
it went over the wall it looks like it's
going to be an automatic double
as wendell is pulling into south third
base but i think they're going to send
him back
scoring on the play will be renfro troy
follows him it's an automatic two-run
double for joey wendell and he's doubled
the raised lead it's four nothing margot
oh for three in this game despite coming
in with a 488 average in an 1193 ops
over his last 15 games
the 1-2 margot swings and misses got him
on the slider and finally
hoyt gets miami out of this inning but
the rays add on to their advantage and
here is garrett cooper who just missed
hitting one out down the left field line
and then he had a good at bat on the
fourth instead of playing out the medium
deep center and the first pitch lifted
towards left right there waiting as
margot the rays have another shutout win
in miami